let's talk about US sanctions on Iran
because the US president keeps piling
them on powerful sanctions will go into
full effect but Iran isn't bowing Baron
Bush my name is Hernan bid on an English
menu on RPG above the heart now
according to this online tracker America
has more sanctions against Iran than it
does on North Korea Cuba Venezuela and
Libya combined so what exactly are those
sanctions and more importantly are they
working the big picture is this the u.s.
and Iran are in a way at war states like
these and their terrorist allies
constitute an axis of evil but they
don't fight face-to-face instead they
antagonize each other
Iran gets involved in conflicts around
the Middle East by backing armed groups
and u.s. rivals like Russia and the u.s.
is main weapon sanctions now the simple
definition of a sanction is an official
order taken against a country in order
to make it obey international law that
could include bans on travel
transactions or trade and in Iran's case
it's all of those any kind of exchange
that directly or indirectly might
benefit the Iranian government or any
agency of it or any individual who may
directly or indirectly be affiliated
with it is prohibited under American law
now we've read the US Treasurys
blacklist for Iran and it is long the
big ones are a ban on Iran's biggest
industry which is oil and a ban on any
kind of financial transactions with Iran
plus its entire steel mining coal
sectors dozens of individual people and
ministries in Iran's government banks
insurance construction companies ships
and aircraft there's even a ban on
Persian carpets one of Iran's the
biggest exports and it's a pistachio
industry
now the penalties for violating those
sanctions are serious the US government
can find a person or company up to
$1,000,000 or ham down a 20-year jail
sentence even if they're not American
because the US has such a strong dollar
and so many transactions are conducted
in dollars it means that US sanctions
would affect any EU company doing
business with Iran between having
sanctions on its main industries and
being blocked from trading with other
countries Iran has become one of the
most isolated economies in the world so
when did this sanctions war start more
than 40 years ago
the US long supported Iran's monarch the
Shah
but in 1979 the Islamic Revolution swept
cleric Ayatollah Khomeini to power a
group of Iranian revolutionaries stormed
the US Embassy and imprisoned its staff
for over a year that led to the very
first round of sanctions on Iran with
the u.s. freezing billions of dollars in
Iranian government assets and it was
just the beginning over the next several
decades Iran came under more
international sanctions over human
rights abuses Iran was also sanctioned
for sending billions of dollars to armed
groups in the Middle East like Hezbollah
in Lebanon or Hamas and Palestine but it
was a Rong's decision to develop nuclear
power that really got the u.s. worried
because Iran now had the tools to build
a nuclear bomb since 2003 a nuclear
crisis has been brewing between Iran the
United States and its European allies
when it was revealed that Iran has two
nuclear facilities that it does not
declare the IAEA so in 2011 the u.s.
together with the UN issued a massive
heap of economic sanctions on Iran to a
stop any money flowing to its nuclear
program and be to pressure Iran into
potentially striking a diplomatic deal
and that part worked in 2015 after long
and tough negotiations a deal known as
the joint comprehensive plan of action
of the sign a historic deal a landmark
nuclear agreement will mean that Iran
has to sharply curtail its nuclear
program the Iranian Foreign Minister
receives a hero's welcome back in Tehran
international sanctions against Iran
will now be lifted we've achieved this
historic progress through diploma
without resorting to another war in the
Middle East the truth is that many US
lawmakers Republicans in particular
didn't trust Iran would keep its end of
the deal neither did one of America's
closest allies Iran's rulers promised to
destroy my country murder my people
perhaps you can understand why Israel is
not joining you in celebrating this deal
[Music]
so as soon as Donald Trump became
president he backed out I am announcing
today that the United States will
withdraw from the Iran nuclear deal
all the old sanctions came back and more
than 700 new ones were issued against
Iranian individuals and companies
it's what the Trump administration calls
its maximum pressure campaign so when
people ask how's the US sanctions
program worked on Iran well that's
debatable these new sanctions have
nearly killed the entire Iran nuclear
deal
and in response the Iranians have said
well what's the point of us holding up
our end so they've now restarted some
low-level nuclear activities and they
will probably continue to do so until
that you take action to deliver on some
of other commitments which they are not
able to deliver because of us pressure
the eventual outcome could be an Iran
withdrawal from the nuclear accord and
also the death of the whole deal
sanctions have managed to [ __ ] Iran's
economy but Iranians are getting around
them
human mules have carried smuggled goods
across the border for years electronics
phones beauty products medicine
cigarettes the list goes on these long
years of sanctions have led the Iranians
to develop many of their own domestic
products inside that have substituted
for those things that they can't bring
in but when sanctions come there's a dip
and then somehow the economy starts
reacting and responding and compensating
and within three or four years it's back
to growth
another question is whether Iran's
government can survive many more years
of instability don't get me wrong it
still has a lot of support but recent
protests across Iranian cities have
exposed some discontent with those in
power
anger frustration and growing concern in
Tehran the protests erupted after Iran's
government which has been strapped for
cash increased the price of fuel to
raise funds in November thousands of
people were arrested rights groups say
more than 300 were killed and at one
point there was a total internet
shutdown Iran's leaders say they were
responding to a bigger threat
oh shoot Allah bonus saws Moneo a masala
barn O'Meara's issued a yeah back home
Ellen bar McCoy you borrow me K air ok
Joe a manta Gabe sang yunusov on ricotta
Ricardo boudin the bottom line is it's
not clear whether the US has huge web of
sanctions is going to lead to any kind
of breakthrough with Iran and there's a
whole debate about whether those
pressure tactics have ever forced any
big changes in places like Cuba or North
Korea where sanctions have been around
for decades those who defend sanctions
say the alternative is an actual war but
neither the u.s. nor Iran nor anybody
else seem to want that
if there's a story or a topic you want
to get your head around let us know get
in touch with us on Twitter or Facebook
and remember to subscribe to our YouTube
channel so you never miss an episode
[Music]